europe after the election seems to be
divided Europe has the austerity policy
failed is it time for making new depths
and how is the ECB trying to stimulate
the European economy once again that's
what I'm talking about with heiko Peters
of Deutsche Bank research mr. Peters
first of all please tell us how has the
d-backs developed um how is the world
economy looking right now I'm the world
economy accelerated I'll accept the
world economy accelerated somewhat in my
the divx increase the level slightly
below 1 and this points to a growth rate
of the world economy of around three and
a half percent and by regions we saw
specially an improvement in the US after
the week you've won numbers now we see
an improvement of the economic situation
an area we saw also an improvement on
sentiments and share in the Japanese
economy and also the Chinese economy is
on increase in the sentiment indicators
in Europe on a whole and the PM is are
also on a level of on an expansionary
level and but the indicator for Germany
the Eiffel index declined somewhat and
and and my butt was still on a
relatively high level nevertheless the
European countries have left the
recession behind but the elections in
Europe have shown a lack of unity what
do you think have has the austerity
policy failed in Europe that's one of
the problems with the moderate and
recovery and which we think will
continue with on a relatively low level
and and the improvement on the financial
markets the refining costs of the Karma
tips are on a relatively low level and
we think with all these improvement on
the financial market on the real economy
and the willingness to really keep on to
the reform path of the last couple of
years is declining and
you can see it by the announcement of
our example France and Italy they
announced they would like to have higher
deficits that would exceed the M agreed
level and these are for the performer
medium term perspective this is a really
worrisome development yeah France and
Spain and Italy want to invest what
seems to be good investments and the
economy but these investments should or
they want to finance it by new depths is
there anything what could convince them
to go back to the structural reforms
that's a that's the weather with a
relatively high unemployment rate and
the weak economic development these
countries and the politicians would like
to implement more stimulated measures
and that's a problem at the moment and
if we look at what they're talking about
it's normally Deb finance government
investments and these normally have only
a positive relatively short effect and
and then and then afterwards after the
short-term stimulus then you see see
only a higher depth level and this is
not a really good development for this
country they should stick to their and
rebalancing of the economy is to
implement more structural reforms hmm
once again the European Central Bank has
lowered the benchmark interest rate to
one point zero point one five percent
this is like coming from a low to a very
very low interest rate can the economy
really benefit from this measure we
think that the the overall effects of
the package the ECB of the package DC be
announced are relatively small and there
are they should increase the credit
development in the periphery countries
and should further give a stimulus for
the whole and Europe euro area and
should bring back be should lower the
the exchange rate and then
should also increase increase the
inflation rate and but on all these
measures and what the ECB announced can
only only work if it's if it's
additionally that the country's stick to
the reforms hmm we will talk about the
measures of the ECB hour later on of the
new pic bazooka of mr. Draghi and you
can watch this interview on DW te /
english / made in germany really we will
talk about the new big bazooka of Mario
Draghi later on how can the measures
help to fight deflate to fly a fighter
deflation and to lower the euro and to
stimulate the economy thank you so far
mr. Peters and you can watch the full
interview on DW de / english / made in
germany